[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
guys i've been using sonos for years
before they even became a sponsor i've
told you this
it is the best
sound system
out there it is so easy to use so
convenient
i have this it's a little box
and you put a little box with a speaker
it is a speaker i have to explain this
to you
these little devices
you could have speakers in each one of
your rooms that has just beautiful sound
and play a different song
throughout the house a different song in
each room i could play a party mode
outside while i'm playing some mazzy
star inside i could
play some def leppard if i want in the
basement and then be playing at the same
time be playing some skinnered
up in the bathroom
it is sweet uh share the joy of
listening on sonos this season it's it's
a remarkable system
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up easy to use and
all work together so you can listen in
any or every room like i just talked
about and bring the family together with
incredible sound for everything
from classic carols to festive films
sonus works with all your streaming
services and control is simple with the
sonos app
your voice using amazon alexa or google
assistant and apple airplay too
spoil the listener in your life with a
gift that keeps on giving
treat gamers and movie lovers to an
immersive home theater experience with
beam keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlists with move
and help relatives relax with hands free
control of their music and more on sonos
one
why would you put sonos on your holiday
list well i'll tell you why because it's
a great gift
it's sleek
they're small devices you can put them
in your home you can easily install them
uh the sound is just incredible
and uh i think this is a wonderful gift
and they're very reasonably priced
from someone who's purchased quite a few
of them
so why don't you do this why don't you
go to sonos.com s-o-n-o-s go to
sonos.com to learn more and wrap up your
holiday shopping you won't be sorry go
to sonos.com
uh tell them rosenbaum sent you you're
listening to inside of you with michael
rosenbaum thanks for being part of my
life thanks for having me be part of
your life uh i i'm sure you're driving
to work right now or you're just
listening in your house and uh
ryan do you ever listen to the episodes
long pause
indicating
probably not
but you're here for them i am here so i
mean you've already listened to them
because you're sitting there
i am here and i take notes and i am
present in the moment you are we have a
we have a great episode we've had some
really great episodes some people in
fact there's some good episodes coming
up i urge you if you're here for
uh ozzy to spy um stick around because
we've got a lot of great guests coming
up and i mean talk about like the the
episode we had
that we just recorded
yes an actor talking about uh you know
really like almost giving up completely
and and like letting go of this world
and uh
that was pretty intense
pretty
yeah some somebody you think that you
know they have it all life they got life
by the balls
career is great and they're just not
happy it comes to show
that you know it doesn't matter how much
money you have or success you have i
mean
look
we're all here we're all doing this
thing called life so
i urge you if you're in trouble or
anything to just get some help and uh
know that there's uh
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
there is
there is but the good kind not the kind
you see when you're dying yes the good
the good light right let's clarify let's
clarify that
what is rosenbaum saying who [ __ ]
knows and who cares
uh
if you want to follow us please do it
ryan tell them where to follow the
podcast on the handles uh inside of you
pawed on twitter inside of you podcast
on instagram and facebook that's right
please subscribe you could watch the
shows on youtube you could listen on
apple and spotify and stitcher and
everywhere else but it really helps
write a review
um tell your friends
we need more people to listen and i want
to thank my patrons those people that
are on patreon.com
inside of you who give to the podcast
more
keep us afloat thank you thank you jason
my editor thank you ryan my engineer and
my my partner in crime here thanks bryce
my producer thanks cumulus thanks
everybody the holidays are here
ryan are you going anywhere
yeah i'm going to hawaii oh yeah you're
going to hawaii with family
holy [ __ ] yeah well that will be fun
though yeah we'll be there for a while
doing uh hawaii things well why are you
doing it with your family doing it while
doing it with amanda's family oh yeah
yeah well you get along with them yeah
so you'll be uh you'll be great it'll be
great and then we're going to a wedding
at the end of it so one of my two of my
friends are getting married [ __ ] in
[ __ ] hawaii so original well if
you're gonna get married yeah go to
hawaii and get married folks um hey as
many of you know i volunteer and uh
supporter for a non-profit uh
that is near and dear to my heart
food on foot is an organization that
helps fight homelessness in los angeles
food on foot helps up to 300 people each
week seeking food clothing jobs and
housing please join me this holiday
season by making a gift of food on foot
your holiday donation will be matched by
food on foot's board doubling your
impact so if you donate 25 food on foot
will receive 50
please visit
foodonfoot.org for more information
i appreciate your help and also echoes
of hope can't
forget foster youth
and uh you know go to echoesofhope.org
i've been with that organization for a
long time and they do so much amazing
work for the youth and for
uh
just go to echoes of hope.org i think
you're going to learn a lot by it and
help help someone out during this
these holidays you know what i'm talking
about ryan i know what you mean it's
good to give back it's good to give back
and i appreciate everybody here also the
inside of you online store we've got
brand new um smallville lunch boxes just
got a shipment of smallville lunch boxes
so if you want one autograph for the
holidays you better uh go to the inside
of your online store got some great
stuff and some holiday specials coming
up and also sunspin.com if you want to
book a zoom with me
and uh if you want any cool swag i see
tom welling and steven amella was
wearing these sunspin shirts that i'm
wearing and hats and i love uh i love it
i love it and also if you want to join
patreon patreon.com inside of you and uh
you know we've got a great episode today
uh ozzy tasfi talks about working on
supergirl she talks about writing an
episode she's like the first actress or
actor that's written an episode
of one of these these shows especially
supergirl and uh
she talks about wanting to be a clown
when she was younger and not like
i mean like a real clown like a clown a
clown school like clown school like
legit like legit
yeah she was not she wasn't clowning
around
uh fantastic episode i really really dug
her can i say that can i say i dug her
yeah i just really enjoyed our
conversation and i think you will too
let's just do it let's get into aussie
testify it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
ozzy tesfi
is that right yeah i did it right yeah
it sounds like such a hollywood name
really not hollywood like oh she's so
hollywood it just sounds like a like
your star oh that's you know it's like
brad pitt
ozzy to spy
michael rosenbaum
doesn't fit which one of these names
doesn't fit
i see your point can you put the maybe
the microphone a little closer to you
like almost like right to you how's that
that's pretty good thanks what do you
think ryan good
yeah yeah
how often
yeah of course
people have been harassing ryan lately
yeah well harassing you my anthony
michael hall bobby lee this is just so
obviously close to uh
everybody
it's like kind of out of the way but
it's just like i'm very much in the priv
do you think that ozzy after this
interview is going to say yeah the guy
to the left i forgot his name
but wasn't he a little close to me
no there's there's multiple pillows
there's pillows between there's a pillow
for it yeah how many people messed your
name up uh
98 of people what have you heard
mm-hmm uh
z a z the last name is always really bad
just just i've heard testify which i was
like how did you easy testify
did you get annoyed
uh i've been dealing with it since the
first day of kindergarten um every time
my name was called in school so i'm
pretty used to it and my full name is
actually ozeb
so i've had it my whole life azeb
testified you have a middle name goytom
azeb goytum
tesfi
that's a lot it's a lot but maybe where
where
where you're at you're you're where fro
where are you from i'm mary tran the
eastern african right
and
is that a typical name so people
wouldn't even think twice hearing it
over there yes and aussie is the typical
name for azep nickname for azeb i didn't
come up with that really yeah yeah i got
lucky but that's a cute name aussie's a
cute name right i feel so validated in
the first yeah did you notice that i had
i would i call because i'm from the
midwest we call them [ __ ]
did you notice that there was a porta
potty outside i did i did notice that
next to where you parked yeah why does
he have a porta potty outside not just
because i'm from indiana i didn't know
if that was for your guests and you're
like i this is where you that's exactly
right it's where the guests uh perform
their duty
no it's because i had some work around
the house so the guys brought their own
port-a-potty that's thoughtful isn't
that thoughtful i think so is it better
than having them come inside to go to
the bathroom they didn't assume they
didn't assume they were like we came
with our just like i came with my own
like waters and i think it's very
thoughtful to not assume
yeah you came your your uh publicist
morgan brought you coffee
she's over there giving a thumbs up but
she didn't ask me if i wanted a car
we didn't consider that but you do make
your own so yeah so look at this uh
kelly olsen and supergirl nadine and
jane the virgin silicon valley melrose
place million little things you're
recurring a million little things yeah
so you're like are you
are you someone are you an actor that
always has to work or you go crazy yeah
talk about that because that that's that
always baffles me how someone has to go
from one project to the next project to
the next project because what happens
and and then tell me what happens to you
when you're not working
uh
it's funny i i a cast made of mine on
jane the virgin uh justin and i are very
similar in this way and we've unpacked
this a lot together i think it's
probably tied to worth and like always
feeling like
there is identity based in in working
validation
yeah and maybe not so much from other
people but for myself like i challenge
myself and then i i'm like oh i could do
that or
uh i'll be able to get another show
quickly after this or so it's it's all
self-inflicted right
so if someone's going out with you
dating you mm-hmm do they feel the
okay they feel the pressure that you
feel because you're like i have to work
i have to do this i have to self-tape i
know how this business can be i it's
it's very internal like i don't put it
on very many people around me it's
definitely
uh
it's a wild place in my mind
really yeah i have it there i say the
airbus once a week which is awesome you
do i do yeah you see that ryan you see
how she just comes out with that ryan's
been going to better help yeah and uh
you know and and i love that he tried it
he gave it a shot and i have friends
that call me go does this better help
work you know because they're a sponsor
but like
therapy
has changed not only my life but
millions of people's lives and and um i
i know david harwood who was on who's on
supergirl he came on the show
and he was so forthcoming and so
open about his you know
his history of like with mental illness
and all these things and i just was in
the first thing you said is i go to
therapy which not all actors do they
kind of want to hide that yeah
yeah i mean but most actors go i just
think
is that true yeah i think so they just
don't maybe share that they do but it's
important and
uh
for me i i started seeing someone weekly
uh because i've got been on and off but
pretty much
uh right right when the pandemic started
i was like okay because i had to sit
still i couldn't work
right i couldn't do it forced to just
stay at home
yeah but that's fine i found things to
do what did you do i started writing so
is is then that that's how it all
happened yeah yeah see what happens
you're forced to write at home yeah and
then you end up writing an episode for
the c series final season of supergirl
for an episode that's crazy it's like oh
you know what i'm going to start
painting and then i'm going to be in the
museum next year look i also
cried and was scared and did all the
things everyone did during the day i
just would carve out a couple hours to
channel that into something and you had
never written before
no i had written but not like a
structured script and i uh got a
teacher
because
you hired a teacher i did i hired a
writing person how do you find a teacher
who will teach you how to write i mean
how where do you find these people i had
a friend well i asked a refer i'm going
to be really honest i i worked with
someone who felt really intense uh who
was an actual writing coach who wasn't a
working writer and the energy was really
off and it gave me a lot of anxiety
i called a female showrunner friend of
mine and said hey do you have any
writers that want to make some money and
are off right now and she's like
actually the perfect person for you and
uh it was a staff writer on one of her
shows and we zoomed and it was like we
got along really well and then two three
days a week we'd hop on
so what was the first conversation you
have so ozzie have you written
um what do you want to write why do you
want to start writing yeah here's from
the
do you just start from where do you
start what do they tell you to do
just right i i
i want i had an idea for a supergirl uh
storyline for kelly um
specifically for your character yeah
yeah because
we had kind of touched on her being a
war vet but there was so much of ptsd
and and how we as a country treat
veterans when they come back home and we
hadn't really looked at that um
and we had sean aston on who played like
love sean
how much do you love working with sean
he's like
they always say like henry winkler is
the nicest guy in the business and i
think sean astin's like number two he
really is and and his daughter is a big
fan of supergirl so he's seen every
episode it's their bonding thing they do
together are you kidding me no you've
seen
every and there's over 100 episodes of
supergirl they've watched how many have
you been in
uh i don't know like 40 or 50.
and so you got the idea and i want to
get into this yeah but i also want to go
back to something you just talked about
you said therapy yeah did you get into
therapy just during code was that the
first time or you had been going for
years i had done it before off and on
but i hadn't consistently
and i had i had like my dog passed and
me too when did your dog pass uh march
my dog passed about five five months ago
so what was that it's about about the
same yeah it was hard 13 years oh my
gosh it's it's brutal and uh
i was
you know alone in vancouver you know my
dog was like my
other half a second companion yeah
so and then a friend of mine it suddenly
passed and
and then and then a week later covid and
our show got shut down so i was like
prime
i'll tell you something i have a really
good girlfriend of mine when all that
stuff went down who
was like i didn't know how to support
you right and
so
what i'm gonna what i did was i called a
bunch of trauma therapists in vancouver
and i uh narrowed it down to two and i
went ahead and booked sessions with them
and told them everything you've been
through so you don't have to so
here you go
and it was like the most thoughtful and
credible i know
she's a really good friend wait so this
person called up a therapist and said
this is what they've gone through they
lost a dog they've been dealing with
this told as much and this person knew
you inside out she like yeah and talked
to a couple and was like she's not gonna
like that person these two women feel
like a good vibe and then yeah and then
talk them through it so that i didn't
have to you know rehash everything so
you just went right into it
[Music]
did you have what's called i had you
know when i went through a breakup they
said i had what's called situational
depression
that it was just this is the situation
you went through a breakup and that's
why you're depressed you're not really a
depressed person per se little did they
know
that uh you know it's not it wasn't just
that situation but was it just a
situation for you was it just like a
sort of a time that you were just having
a tough time getting through
uh i think it's a little of both i
definitely can uh
i don't know it's really hard to assess
coming out of three and a half four
years in vancouver i think too because
they're so isolated and i definitely
have seasonal depression up there and so
and and the winters are so long i'm just
not sure i've gotta reassess where i
land now that i'm i'm back but
um
it was it was hard again because my
situation bled into a two-year pandemic
so it wasn't like
you know my dog passed and and then i
was getting out of it and there was like
all
crazy fires of the world going on and
um i don't know so to be determined
maybe i'll get back to you on that what
what helps you what what helps you get
through days what helps you do you have
a regiment do you have something that
you do
what is that i wake up and uh make
coffee this is like my favorite thing
the simple things right the simple
things and i like making like frothing
the milk and i find all that uh relaxing
and then i journal for me like doing
um morning pages i guess they're called
uh for the artist's way but doing three
pages and just letting everything
kind of come out helps a lot if i wake
up with anxiety um and then i do breath
work sometimes what kind of breath work
uh
wim hof
wim hof is that the deep [ __ ] that's
like the you it's apparently outlined
your body but you there's an app you can
follow and uh um i'm breathing now i'm
like sorry i'm like you hold it and and
then you it almost feels like you're
gonna faint i mean but you it's it's
pretty incredible and and years ago uh
macad brooks uh on who's jimmy olsen
james olsen right he really tried to get
me into it and i just wasn't
into it and then um
uh cass made on my little things alison
miller she got me to
do it she got on on facetime with me i
was like we're doing this together and
i've been because i wasn't sleeping
it was post dog dying and then
i slept like fully that night well and i
was like all right this works for me
were you one of those people that would
take any medications like you know
because i for a while there i would take
xanax or ambien and they say it's the
worst and it was the worst i think it
messed me up pretty good i i right when
all of that went down at the same time
i did take something for anxiety but i
think it was like a day or two and then
not really i really like to feel the
pain
it helps with your acting it does no i
don't i yeah i don't know i try to find
uh natural as much as i can ways to
especially because it was
something that i felt like i had to work
through right um yeah what are some
natural ways like
obviously
i mean it's true like sweating and
getting active i'm a big uh
um
stanley park blue bike rider stanley
park guys is in vancouver british
columbia i was there for seven years for
smallville and i know about stanley cup
park and when she talks look it's the
most one of the most beautiful cities in
the world but during the winters it's
gray and it rains for seven months and
as beautiful as it is it can be taxing
so that with covid with your dog passing
with all these things you have to have
this regimen so you're doing breath work
you're going to stanley park you're
exercising you're sweating the good
thing good and bad but we we shut down
so i was able to come back here right
after all that happened um
and so i was around friends and family
in a safe in a safe environment but
therapy really is is is big and you go
every week every week
yeah for the last year i i think i make
the mistake of like going to therapy and
then uh i go oh i feel okay
and then i don't and then i go down down
down down until i need therapy again and
it's something that i think you need to
have upkeep is that what's called
you have to just be on top of it i
looked at ryan
ryan just started going to therapy
looking at you silent nod of like i'm
just here to support you yeah yeah yeah
i i've fallen off before i just haven't
maybe
honestly like felt like okay yeah i'm
good
stopping just because it's been a big
transitional time and then when we went
back to shooting uh the border was
closed so we were we were locked down
um
hardcore
only interacting kind of with your
castmates
um
no one can come in or out of canada for
for us it was the last season was what
11 months 11 months you were there i
think so september until august now you
had to i know you're not going to tell
me this but you had to get sick and
tired of your castmates yeah i'm not
touching that no but jesus i mean look
you hang out with anybody for 11 months
or 11 hours yeah you're gonna be like
okay i just you need to have a different
uh change of scenery the good thing is
is
because there's so many shows that were
locked down like you i had friends on
other shows and i so there was community
where you didn't have to hang out with
people you worked with necessarily um
not for any other reason then you're
with them all the time uh and a lot of
people had family so i didn't have i
didn't have anyone up there but most
people like you know kyla has a husband
and kids and they had their own worlds
so you didn't have anybody except your
dog yeah
and when did the dog pass in march march
and then i ended up rescuing when i came
home to join the writers room i rescued
a pup in december what a damn treat what
kind of dog
she's some sort of poodle mix her name's
daisy she's she's a
somebody told me recently she was my
teacher was like great really yeah
isn't it amazing how
just having an animal in the house i it
just elevates your your whole
disposition like your whole
feeling like i could be really sad and i
walk in and there's this
unconditional little thing yeah that
just kisses me and loves me and wants me
to take her out and you met blanche she
jumped on your publicist
jeez i don't know what the hell that was
but she's
felt i felt very um supported and secure
and loved and i was like solid she was
like this is where we're going yeah
exactly she led you the way she led you
to the podcast room so daisy you feel
like daisy really helps you out
yeah i mean she's tricky she had i
didn't you know she came with a lot of
issues uh what are the issues
she's really loud like in the streets
you know she like barks at every like a
paper bag and it's you know i'm like you
gotta chill out she's very attached
because she was abandoned multiple times
and so and she was actually a um
a china kill shelter meat dog so i had
her recipe yeah so that's like dark wow
uh almost eaten did you barely get her
in time
she's really cute i feel like it was
only a matter of time for someone again
someone was gonna eat that little thing
now yeah yeah but now i tell the story
in front of her and she has a reaction
for sure too she understands she's like
it's too soon i'm not ready to uh to
unpack that with you yet
but um
yeah i it's so funny i
i didn't and i've never talked about
this but i also didn't i was very social
media uh heavy with my with my last with
george the dog that passed yeah and i
didn't with daisy for a long time and um
i felt like she knew
she was like what about me am i pretty
enough totally i would do like lives and
she would all of a sudden start pacing
in a place she's never pace that happens
to be in she's like the girlfriend
that's like i know you posted pictures
of your ex and like we've been dating
for a while i don't know what's going on
yeah
um i need to more people in vancouver
clearly this is what i'm psychoanalyzing
obviously well it's well it's hard it's
like you have to have i'm sure you have
some you people yeah you know those
those those
friends that you face time constantly
that the one or two that you need to
help get you through things just seeing
their face makes you smile are you close
with your uh with your family with your
parents yeah my mom and i are really
close were they in l.a in l.a yeah but
my mom you know
she uh is is not married so she was also
in it alone
and older so it was a very different
experience of fear for her
um so it was it was kind of supporting
her more than
uh
you know just wanting her to feel good i
still got to be around people my nervous
system got resets of being around energy
on set i wasn't isolated right um
and again i there really is a community
like of people that i'm really close
with on on some of the other shows that
i hang out with all the time who who are
some of these people um uh candace
patton and i really right
and uh javisi and i are really close and
cameras on batwoman and wow yeah we have
like a we have we we you know kim does
we do game nights what kind of games you
guys play
taboo is a big one
um
what's taboo taboo's the one where you
you write an answer in there there's a
fake answer you get a word and you can't
say like five words underneath it and
then there's someone with a buzzer by
your ear which gets very loud with a
bunch so like it's uh kennedy for
instance john f kennedy you can't say
shot you can't say head you can't say
president you can't say marilyn monroe
can't say marilyn monroe something like
that that's fun it's fun we should play
some taboo and then there's some there's
like a a game with like dice i don't
even know what it's called that was
introduced into the left right center
yes is that the drinking game but we do
it with money we do it with money so you
bet money and you know who tends to win
this game which is very frustrating
david ramsey who doesn't need mc yeah
and i'm like you are the last why do you
say david ramsey doesn't need it is it
because he's just been working for so
long he's been working for so long he
was like on the the og show of arrow and
he's like directing everything and he's
like non-stop he is he's coming on the
podcast too and he keeps texting me says
hey rosenbaum i'm just i'm busy i'm
doing this thing i want to come on
he's great i know you worked closely
with him yeah
he directed the super girl episode
yeah um
what was it called blind spot blind
spots i knew that yeah
inside he was brought to you by helix
sleep
um
what would you say ryan the number one
thing in life is besides you know being
happy but what's important well i think
one step to being happy is getting a
good night's sleep that's for damn sure
getting a good night's sleep being
comfortable on your bed
you know waking up feeling refreshed
every day helix sleep is gonna do that
for you guys helix sleep check this out
they have a quiz that takes it's just
two minutes it's so easy i i did this
it's not this is simple you take a
two-minute quiz to complete and match
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress
for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
you just wouldn't with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for you and the way you sleep
and everybody's unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from soft
medium and firm mattresses i took the
quiz i'm a medium i'm like the porridge
you know like the medium too hot too
cold for me right down the middle that's
what i'm that's what i'm doing and they
have mattresses great for cooling you
down if you sleep hot and even a helix
sleep mattress for plus size sleepers
uh it's been awesome getting messages
from you guys telling me how much you uh
really appreciate helix i've had friends
say come on is helix really this stuff
is it really good and i tell you i have
people always ask me friends is this
product good is this product good
i really don't like to read products
unless i'm sold on them unless i really
believe in them and so there you have it
so if you're looking for a mattress just
take the quiz order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go get a mattress
store uh go to a mattress store again
it's that easy um and you don't need to
take my word for it ryan uh helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine does that tell you something
wow just go to helixsleep.com
inside take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will and helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash inside that's helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep dot com slash inside helix sleep
dot com slash inside for up to two
hundred 200 off and two free pillows
inside of you is brought to you by true
bill ryan do you know why free trials
renew without your consent so they can
get you yeah it's a business scam out to
get you ryan they want you to forget
yeah don't let greedy corporations
pocket your money download truebill to
take control of your subscriptions this
is so easy to use truebill is the new
app that helps you identify and stop
paying for subscriptions you don't need
want or simply forgot about on average
people save up to 720 bucks a year with
true bill because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel true bill
makes it incredibly simple just link
your accounts and true bill will cancel
your unwanted subscriptions in one tap
it's so true ryan too because you know
even when you get like an app uh or a
subscription on um
you know an app when you're watching a
movie like i won't say their names but
like
fizzy plus
or something like that
you know uh or you want a trial a lot of
times when you have trials with certain
companies all of a sudden you're done
with the trial but it just kicks in
because you have to put your credit card
information there so now you're screwed
and you're like well i've been paying
this for six months and you don't know
it true bill
helps you find all those things and gets
rid of them so you save money it's
really extraordinary i love true bill
and your true bill concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to
truebill has over 2 million users and
helped save them over 100 million bucks
good lord don't fall for subscription
scams folks start canceling today at
truebuild.com slash inside go right now
these guys are going to help you out
truebill.com
inside it could save you thousands a
year
truebill.com
inside
so go go back did you always want to be
an actor did you since you were a little
girl because i read somewhere that you
wanted to be a clown i did is that true
yeah how old were you not like a cool i
just i feel like people assume that it's
like a cool cirque du soleil clown like
i wanted to do kids birthday parties you
really were aspiring to something i did
i
i remember in kindergarten pulling a
clown aside and being like listen just
give it to me straight now like
how did you get on this path what do i
need to do to set myself up to win um
and she was like you should not be a
clown
is that what she said yeah you do not
want to do it you do not want to do it
squeaks though it wasn't like actually
she had just done like a balloon animal
and i was like listen lady you you learn
that somewhere can you fast track me
yeah and i think you have to really love
children mm-hmm do you love children uh
i don't think that that was a
consideration for me because you were a
child i was a child so you didn't think
about that i think it was like
clown clothes balloons
build your own schedule feels like fun
yeah fun you make people happy you like
there's you know
you're mobile everything's just in your
car and then you can like when did those
dreams fade third grade third grade all
right so you were really young i mean i
don't i don't remember wanting to do
anything except the moonwalk when i was
in i mean i but i wanted to be a clown
from from like preschool to third grade
so it was a good five five years of my
life so i and i i pursued it heavily in
that time but no third grade i was like
okay this isn't where are you
is this thing there's some solid perks
though i'm kind of getting sold on
clowns right yeah getting sold on sold
on clowns
there's the name of your next album sold
on
clown yeah well what what did the
passion
uh where did it go to
i mean i'm the child of immigrants some
first-gen kid so then it was you have to
be a doctor or a lawyer an engineer
those are we've escaped war it's for you
to have opportunity
so these are the things that we know you
you know you can do and be successful in
this country so i i truly thought like
i'm not good at math so i'm not gonna be
a very good engineer i don't like the
sight of blood i'm not gonna be a good
doctor and so i was like okay i guess
i'll be a lawyer and then that kind of
carried me through college through
college so you went to high school and
then you said i'm gonna be a lawyer yeah
you went to college did you start taking
like classes to be a lawyer planning i
studied business but i was pre-law here
like did you take constitutional law con
law
did you learn all those dates cbs
radford 1973 and had to learn i did i
did yeah really none of it is stuck but
yeah because i and and you know to my
own fault i didn't intern with an
entertainment lawyer until my senior
year and then and then i interned with
the corporate lawyer and i was like this
is not what i want to do why didn't i do
this earlier so you're really smart
i'm okay no i i i got good grades in
college i did i was you made the parents
proud ap classes and god i never took
those classes
i mean even chemistry chemistry 101 i
got out of
because i couldn't handle it i just
couldn't handle school i just i don't
know how i got through it i probably
cheated a lot
i'm not kidding i probably cheated a lot
in fact probably i did i remember
cheating on certain papers and i just
was slower i just i couldn't i had add i
was all over the place so it was very
hard for me to concentrate
were you
um
it sounds like you were really focused
in college yeah i was pretty type a and
you didn't do any acting in college yeah
my my best friend growing up was a very
successful teen actress
and i got to witness
it through her and not the best who was
that
her unmarried name was lily sobieski
i i know that name she's done she was
like the teen she did a movie called the
glass house yes
blonde hair yes yeah see i remember that
that's crazy that you remember that yeah
so i got to like see through her uh kind
of the chaos of it i was like i don't i
just i have no desire i get to go to
like the teen choice stores with her but
i don't have to do any work it was the
best of and you grew up in l.a yeah and
so you got to see hollywood firsthand
growing up yeah and you live sort of i
don't know i don't want to say
vicariously through her but you got to
see hollywood through her yeah yeah and
you had no desire none
yeah that's crazy because all the
attention she's getting and the people
and the free [ __ ] don't you love free
[ __ ]
but i kind of got it by association
so again i got the best of it without
having to do it and i went to this weird
not weird it was great but a very small
french high school here in la and so
there were a couple other actors uh that
went to our school
um we're just gonna name we're gonna i
love the name yeah we have a game we
play that when you name drop you have to
drop something like
drop a pen
oh yeah so i work with clint eastwood
and then you just drop something
i had no choice in who i was educated
next to but we had uh
um claire danes went there and jessica
biel and that was really it big names
yeah and it was a french school yeah
international french school so there
were kids from all over the country do
you speak french i used to really
fluently and i'm okay
too that's it okay
i just say i love you how are you doing
mm-hmm
yeah
well see so you know some you can
understand okay
yeah so when was it that you sort of go
i'm gonna try this
um
i don't think i've ever said talked
about this but my senior year of college
i went through a crazy breakup and i uh
just want i was at i went to school in
northern california went to cal berkeley
and and i
uh
my my friend there was like an
opportunity for the show and i didn't i
just wanted to get out of berkeley
pretty much i was like i'm going through
this breakup i need to get out of town
and that was when southwest had their
like flight from
the one hour flight you could take
anywhere pretty much yeah um and so i
just came home and then i auditioned for
this like weird nickelodeon thing wait
what made you even know that there was a
nickelodeon thing so my like friends
my best friend was was still kind of
acting but like her man it was just
something that was like
physically very uh specific that worked
i don't remember what it was pretty much
like
surfer girl number five but
it doesn't need to surf but can wear a
bikini
and i was like i'll do i'll do it and so
i i came down audition and then um and
they were like oh actually we're gonna
make this a regular and you you you got
it and
uh and you had lines yeah what'd you say
do you remember your lines remember
no i won't go over there yeah something
like that that's a really cool wave yeah
something like that that's a really cool
wave yeah you're a really great surfer
yeah
it really wasn't about the acting
you were just a beauty i think they just
it was not it was not a deep uh
not demanding no and my mom was like
you're not dropping out of college for
something you don't want to do but then
it was enough for me to kind of be like
oh maybe i'm interested in this
so you enjoyed it you're on set and you
started to enjoy this i didn't i just
kind of was curious
but then my first real thing i got right
after college was at one of those
telenovela my 13 soapy shows right and
it was filmed in san diego and that i
loved like i was like oh i i did i think
60 episodes of that because how did that
come about uh i came back she was also a
surfer party girl
so we're getting typecast early on in
our careers i think we all get we have
that yeah and and it was great it was
one of the best experiences and then i
fell in love with it working
really it was very and even then i was
like oh maybe i'll still go to law
school like it had i hadn't committed
until i was
well into a tv show how pissed are your
parents at this point
well i think they were pissed i think
becoming a superhero helped um because
that's just cool and
um seeing that one sheet i think they
were like oh and no no i'm the first
from um my country to ever be a
superhero so well not on the telenovela
show or whatever no supergirl supergirl
exactly but that was years later then
they were pissed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but they just
didn't understand that you could
they thought it was a hobby and so
they're like why are you spending so
much time on a hobby they didn't
understand that you could actually have
a career in it because there were no
examples of that but you're saying mom
i'm making money and how much are you
making at that time like an episode
i don't remember i think it was like a
soap opera salary i mean good probably
like
a couple thousand a week more than that
12 grand a week 12 grand a week yeah for
a soap opera yeah that's pretty good
that was straight out of college so oh
my god everyone else was like yeah i was
like they're like screwed being a lawyer
screw being a doctor look at all this
money you're gonna make
and all i have to do is be in a bikini
and make out with random people didn't
you have a lot of lines on that soap
opera yeah we did like like an episode a
day okay we'll see let me ask this then
so if you're doing
you go from really nothing going from
surfer girl yeah to having all this
dialogue yeah it sounds like you you
don't you don't just fall into that and
learn lines and memorize them and you're
off to the races don't you have to get
training or die i did i did that one
once i realized that it was happening i
got like i had a coach and i i worked at
it a lot how hard was it to learn all
those lines uh really hard but it's like
a muscle memory for whatever reason i
also just come out of college where i
was like writing thesis statements and
like was so my mind was so exercised
that it was weirdly
probably not as hard as it was for other
people on the show
that um hadn't just come out of school
you have a really high iq don't you i
don't know i bet you i like that you're
i just look at you as if you would know
uh i would guess it's probably in the
130s 140s
i'll take it i'm probably
108.
have you ever taken her iq test i think
a long time ago but i don't remember
exactly what it was or maybe i'm just
not telling you because i'm embarrassed
ryan do you know your iq is no idea do
you know i was at a party once
and sharon stone
dropped the drop
just drop name drop
she was at the party going my iq is
through the roof
and i'm like oh my god shut the [ __ ] up
are you serious she was going
everybody's just oh no like they have
told me my iq is like genius
off the tr is that something you go
around saying no i don't yeah i don't i
guess if you're sharing stones yeah i
don't know i don't know so your parents
at this point you're making money you're
you're making someone of a living you're
doing things are they at this point like
going hey we're proud of you like
continue this
no not yet
but i also then didn't work then i hit
you know like it's it's um they were
like okay we'll we'll back off a little
bit
uh but then when i wasn't working for
years and just auditioning and once i
fell in love with it it um went away
which so you hit a lull yeah then they
were like okay so are we done
and did you think maybe you
were i've had moments i will say my mom
came down to visit when i was shooting
that show and saw the spark of passion
and bless her
she pushed me through a lot of the that
i might want to quit because once she
saw that i was really passionate about
it she was like you can do anything so
i'm going to support you in in in doing
this why were you so passionate what is
it about acting that makes you
passionate
i mean i
i l i am very indecisive of what i want
to do with my life so the fact that you
get to have many different lives
uh by playing different characters feels
really cool
um
that feels exciting to me
there's few moments where i felt like
there's nowhere else i want to be
usually i'm like always thinking ahead
or trying to do or i just feel really
aligned and those have been in acting
situations when they've happened
um
yeah like in the show i'm doing now i've
had it's been so great that i'm like oh
i forgot how much i
love acting what million little things
yeah
yeah is it certain
you have to really is a lot of dialogue
for you too a lot of dialogue and it's
just two people having a conversation
there's no one flying over you there's
no explosions and
i it's i love that so you're saying
supergirl was easy for you
it wasn't easy because i
it it looks cooler being a superhero
than it is when you're doing it you're
like oh this is really hard and
uncomfortable and so it was challenging
in a different way right um and and
honestly kyle's a great actor so for
working with her was always amazing
because um
if i ever got comfortable she would
throw something at me to get me like
back on my my game in a scene or
all right is super cool the first is is
the biggest show that you've gotten or
do you think um jane the virgin was that
was probably your first biggest show
yeah and that was a popular show i mean
didn't the cast or something get
nominated for a golden globe in that
yeah our first season right so it was
something that people did you ever watch
it ryan no i never thought yeah but a
lot of people did yeah and so that was
your first big break because that's
something that your your mom and your
dad sort of like their eyes open like oh
wait a minute our little girl is is
doing something big now
mom yes dad still wasn't sold
she still wasn't sold still wasn't we're
gonna get there but i think
jane was so unexpected in that uh i came
on episode two right after the pilot and
then by by our
by episode nine we were at the golden
globes and peabody awards and people's
choice awards so it was it was very uh
jarring in in an exciting way but it
bonded a lot of us i think because we
were like what are we doing in essex
well it had to be exciting going from
what are they called tele novella yeah
was that right telenovela shows soap
operas to surfer girl
you know to
jane the virgin and being at the golden
globes yeah that had to be like an
eye-opener for you for for the people
around you going hey she's because a lot
of times you know we do not great work
yeah or we do great work and something
that's not great yeah it was the first
time people really
like were fans and watched they paid
attention to you yeah they're like she's
something to look at she's something to
more of the sh the show like i think
people have a very
intense emotional attachment to it
um i was at this this book store in
vancouver that i go to a lot and the
woman that was working out front like uh
came up and was like i just want you to
know like
this jane the virgin was my pandemic
like my brother passed and she started
crying and it was like very but like
that's really common for that show
because it to feel good and people it's
like their safe place wow so it was the
first time i had that where
people were sharing very intimate
information because i was a part of
something that was
special to them how often do people come
up to you and recognize you how often do
you get that
um it depends in vancouver much more i
think just because we're all there uh
people know in l.a no one gives a [ __ ]
because it's like
actors are everywhere yeah yeah right
yeah and still i think jane is the one
because it feels personal i think it's
like when someone shares something about
themselves that's vulnerable and and
someone's experienced that uh then you
want to come up and share that with that
person whether it's your mental health
struggles or
um
you know a million things deals with
with suicide uh as a storyline then you
get people that come up to you and and
want to share that and so i think with
jane specifically anywhere um whether
it's like immigration story lines they
they want to tell their story they want
to tell you their story right yeah how
do you
cause like the thing is you're having a
bad day you're having whatever kind of
day and people come up to you you sort
of have to give them that attention are
you someone who could just turn it on
really quickly and and be like hey great
thank you so much or [ __ ] off
there are some people that can easily
just be like you know i met so and so
and that rosenbaum is just an [ __ ]
and i'm like i was having a [ __ ] bad
day i i lost my dog people don't know
what you what you're going through or
what you went through but do you how do
you feel about that do you
i try i think sometimes maybe i've not
been as connected and warm if i'm having
a bad day but i always i always try um
and i think with supergirl specifically
it's usually girls and uh they look up
to so many of us girls and so for me
that always they they're so sweet and
it gets me out of a bad mood weirdly
meeting them because they're so excited
and
kind and yeah
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy
boy i can't tell you how much this works
i get emails all the time thank you for
talking about better help thank you for
getting me into to therapy
ryan does better help i do
i just you know uh i just had a friend
this morning i was facetiming with him
and his wife said you know my kid's
dealing with depression
and uh do you know any of your
therapists i go better help online
therapy because they're in the middle of
sort of nowhere and you don't need to go
anywhere you can facetime or text or you
know it's it's better help is just uh
it's amazing it just helped you out yeah
it's uh it's convenient
yeah it has been good i have gotten a
lot out of it well i like that look
whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you better help is
secure online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with a
licensed professional
therapists betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime folks send a message to your
therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
you need and that may happen you know
you meet someone the first time you may
not vibe with them you change a
therapist better help it's that easy
and i i completely recommend this uh so
many people have told me it works uh
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy by a landslide if you
ask me and financial aid is available
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join over the 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help ryan
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by better
help and our listeners get 10 off their
first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside give it a shot
better help inside of you is brought to
you by sonos guys i've been using sonos
for years before they even became a
sponsor i've told you this
it is the best
sound system
out there it is so easy to use so
convenient
i have this it's a little box
and you put a little box with a speaker
it is a speaker i have to explain this
to you
these little devices you could have
speakers in each one of your rooms that
has just beautiful sound and play a
different song
throughout the house a different song in
each room
i could play a party mode outside while
i'm playing some mazzy star inside i
could
play some def leppard if i want in the
basement and then be playing at the same
time be playing some skinnard
up in the bathroom it is sweet uh share
the joy of listening on sonos this
season it's it's a remarkable system
make the sound system on your wish list
a reality with speakers and sound bars
that are easy to set up easy to use and
all work together so you can listen in
any or every room like i just talked
about and bring the family together with
incredible sound for everything
from classic carols to festive films
sonos works with all your streaming
services
and control is simple with the sonos app
your voice using amazon alexa or google
assistant and apple airplay 2
spoil the listener in your life with a
gift that keeps on giving
treat gamers and movie lovers to an
immersive home theater experience with
beam keep your fitness loving friends
motivated with great sound for their
workout playlists with move
and help relatives relax with hands free
control of their music and more on sonos
1.
why would you put sonos on your holiday
list well i'll tell you why because it's
a great gift it's sleek
they're small devices you can put them
in your home you can easily install them
uh the sound is just incredible
and uh i think this is a wonderful gift
and they're very reasonably priced
from someone who's purchased quite a few
of them
um so why don't you do this why don't
you go to sonos.com s-o-n-o-s
go to sonos.com to learn more and wrap
up your holiday shopping you won't be
sorry go to sonos.com
uh tell them rosenbaum sent you
how many
episodes of supergirl did you do before
before covid i guess there was quite a
few right yeah i guess two seasons two
seasons of that so it wasn't until then
covet hit where you started to want to
write yeah and that's when you got into
this whole thing where you had this
about racial injustice and all these
thoughts for supergirl and um how did
that so so you you wanted to write an
episode is that what you ultimately
wanted to do was to write an episode of
supergirl was that what got you into the
writing or you that kind of came about
so
i think you know it was also the
covet and black lives matter and it was
this really activated time and i think
just even having gone through it what i
was saying i went through with loss of a
close friend and my my dog and
uh i was unpacking a lot of stuff and
and
realizing within myself things that i
pushed down and said was okay that
weren't uh and trauma things were coming
up for me again i was doing a lot of
therapy
and uh so i started to write more for
myself and then um stories that i was
like i want to tell these stories and i
have why why can't i more as like a
producer like i want to get someone to
do this and i think i realized if i
can't write it's a disadvantage and it
would only help me to learn how to right
and for the upcoming season of supergirl
i really wanted to tell a war vet story
and
go a little deeper
uh in the sean aston kind of where we
started but like really explore it and
how do you do that because it sounds so
daunting that you know you get the show
going on for so many years
that you want to just jump in and write
an episode or
because where does it fit because you
got to think there's arcs and there's
episodes that lead to other episodes and
they're crossing into each other and
there's like then they have the malta
universe or whatever the arrowverse yeah
and all these things so
i mean it takes a lot of chutzpah as the
jews say
i'm a jew i could say that because if i
said as the jews say and i was like if i
was black and i said it or if i was you
know not jewish yeah i'd get in trouble
probably nowadays wouldn't i but you're
like i'm good but i'm good because i'm a
jew so the jews say i think i think
i think you're good i think anyone's
good anyone's good saying that yeah but
where did the chutzpah of like going in
and like writing an episode because
that's you sort of wrote
a piece right yeah you wrote an episode
yeah
but but but again it was my version of
it had nothing to do with the storylines
on the show i knew what was happening
with my character because our showners
really did end of season beginning of
season told you you're pretty much a
whole arc so we had a really good idea
right okay that's good
um but again
so i wrote this with that idea of that
also i was um
finding my voice a lot because
i've always been someone that never
wants to be difficult and to the to to a
detriment of myself
and
i was starting to realize that speaking
up for myself didn't make me difficult
um
and asking for things that i want was
something i had never really done i just
like oh i'm just happy to be here i
don't wanna
and i started realizing uh
that if i didn't do that that it wasn't
it wasn't going to go well and anyone
could call you anything like no matter
what you're doing so you might as well
like
stand and stand for yourself and and um
i started asking for things and
what were you asking for
i had called
my the share winner and creator of jane
the virgin jenny irman and i i was
talking through some stuff with her
because i'm still very close with her
and i was like i want to make these
shows and these are my ideas and she
loved one of them and she was like let's
start developing it so so at the same
time we had brought in a writer that was
a friend of mine from jane and we were
doing these mini rooms and so we were
creating something um based on a time in
my life uh while i was writing this
super cool thing with this writing coach
so that it was very serendipitous in
that by the time i they were like we
want you to write an episode likely the
storyline that i had written
um
i was like okay i feel i just
worked with this genius woman creating
something from nothing i i think i could
i know these characters so well i've
been
on the show for a couple years now i
feel like so you pleaded this case to
them you really no no i this is all in
my head
my head is the wild place okay
on the outside i was like here's the
sample i'd love to explore this i love
writing i've been working on it and then
they they really loved it they were like
we'll send this off and then our other
producers in the studio loved it and
then that was it pretty much yeah and
then covid and then and then every like
life got complicated and coveted
stretched out longer melissa was having
a baby um uh and then we found out it
was our final season and so they had to
scrap the story lines and start over but
because they committed to an episode
they kept their word and
uh did you have to rewrite something
rewrite it oh i started from scratch so
i had to join the writer's room so i i
had to wait a minute so they scratched
the episode that you were going to do
the whole season all season because it's
all changed it's the final one they had
to redo everything for the third time
and so that had to be a little
disappointing since you wrote something
you're really happy with it now you had
to start from scratch and but they still
were interested i i was like this isn't
gonna happen anymore it's fine in my
mind this is their way of saying we like
you you're so sweet but no thanks and i
would get i would get you know it's the
final season of a show that's been on
for a long time
uh but but there was there was a
three or four episodes that i didn't do
because i joined the writers i really
feel like
i just kept showing up and uh were they
annoyed
no i think they were like pleasantly
surprised you just kept showing up every
day would you be quiet or would you be
assertive and go i have an idea what if
this happened yeah and they were cool
with that they're like this [ __ ]
actors in the room i would wait i would
wait until everybody spoke i would wait
until there was like a a stall and then
i would really think about what i was
going to say and then i would i would
only try to offer solutions or with with
my character or kyler's character i felt
comfortable speaking up uh with
representation and certain things like
you can't do that or
you know for this arc storyline let's
bring in guest stars
you know to make it more authentic we
and and things like that and they were
really well received but i'm really
close with that right i've always been
closer with our writers uh than than
anyone on the show so a lot of them were
my my friends so then you kept just
pitching these story ideas yeah and they
said we love it write it
yeah well we did i was in the room for a
month so we did
three episode but broke the arcs for
three episodes all together
and then as we were doing it people were
going off right in their episodes and
then we broke uh blind spots
pretty roughly but they gave me a lot of
leeway and then um i went off and wrote
it with uh jay who is the co-writer of
the episode
and uh wasn't that were you nervous
i i i think i i here's the thing
i do something and don't think about how
hard or scary it is until i'm like god i
wish i was you 85
and then i have a panic at 85 but i've
usually committed i have to do it and so
i'm like i'm almost there i've got to
just buckle down and then i push past
the last bit and what was the most
important thing when you were writing
this that you were thinking of that this
is what i want to come across this is
what i want people to understand because
i i felt like it was
it was really cool how you said
something about
the superheroes that they that they
they're part of the problem that
supergirl and
all her justice league they were part of
the problem with racial injustice and
all these things
that's that's a difficult
subject that's that's hard to tackle for
anyone yeah
yeah especially when you're you know
doing notes calls and in rooms and
this character has been built up as the
hero that's the best of everyone
and and then you have to you know it's
it's it's interesting to watch how
people react to those scenes when
they're reading them because it people
get very um defensive it's almost like
it's them that is being attacked
um
but
i
you bear down i did
you just said eff it i'm gonna do this
yeah
yeah and and i even with our fans i find
a lot of them
we were lacking empowerment of oneself
and it's like they're not superheroes
aren't gonna save the day like the whole
point of this is that hopefully you take
some of that for yourself and empower
yourself we all have a superhero in us
yes we're all we all can be superheroes
yes by being good people yes and not
relying on someone to rescue you in your
everyday life this could be translated
to so many things wow
um and so what does it look like when
you expect someone to rescue and they
fail you like what how painful is that
how do you step up for yourself how do
you show up from yourself so
i think there were themes in it that
hopefully uh people that watch the show
that aren't like oh i'm not that so i
can't um it overwrote that
you know i read somewhere where david
ramsey who was going to direct who
directed it blind spots
you worked very close with him and you
also worked closely with every
department with like from props to them
saying to the set design to whatever i
mean you weren't just writing you were
designing you were
an integral part of the whole process
yeah they really
later i asked one of our sharingers
robert i was like what what did you was
that intentional or did you just not
realize that and he was like i knew
you'd sink or swim and i knew swim and
they just yeah like casting decisions i
got to cast it i got to go on location
scouts which i know writers don't
normally do and go over all the
locations approve
prop guns and
little knickknacks table like my the
restaurant that's a lot you might as
well have directed the episode but like
my type a controlling personality
i loved it i was i've never been more
engaged it was hard going back to just
being an actor honestly i was like
everything was so personal i had a sign
of a restaurant i came out of that had
my mom's name on it and was ethiopian
food because she always wanted to have
an ethiopian restaurant so our first
location i built out was a restaurant
and she when they sent me the approvals
and i i don't even know if i told my
show notice this but i texted my mom so
she actually picked out everything for
her restaurant that was on tv are you
serious yeah so i got to make it
personal
oh man and i think you could feel that
uh energy and
and then um talk about therapy a lot of
those speeches i would
voice record unless i'd be in my
apartment with daisy just sobbing as i'm
like yelling you know it's like what you
do in the shower but i essentially just
record it
wow and then write it out and
yeah so it's real emotion yeah yeah it
was real
everything i everything that was said
was something i felt so at this point
when this episode comes out
you've made dad proud
has that happened yet at this point he
was like come on when the superhero uh
when the guardian one sheet came out a
lot of young
eritrean girls that were like friends of
kids
my dad's friends kids
were so excited to see someone that
looked like them be a superhero i think
that he was like okay
and to be the first of something because
you're a vigilante right
ultimately james olson your brother yep
he was a guardian and then he skips town
and then you become a guardian yeah see
you see how i put this [ __ ] together
yeah that's impressive that's impressive
yeah i didn't look at that i don't have
that written down
yeah that's true yeah so so but dad was
yeah pretty pleased yeah yeah
yeah that made you feel good
yeah it did i got it i'm proud for you
of you and that made me happy i like
that yeah
what's it like
had you ever kissed another woman before
you got this role
before you got yeah you had sure yeah
i don't think this is yeah
i'm sure on a show
are you are you talking real life
we're gonna skip through this well no
what's it well why are we going to
morgan's like hang on a second no but
i'm just wondering on a tv show have you
ever had to kiss her i think so you
think so i i would remember that
if i had to kiss a man which i have yeah
uh it got cut i don't know maybe i was a
bad kisser i don't know why but it was
jason isaacs in sweet november with
kennel reeves and charlie's throne
and i made out with him in a scene in
the background and they cut it and the
director was so like oh that was great
if you could do it again it was really
touching no of [ __ ] man i sounded french
what was what is it let me do it again
okay um michael um jason that's really
great but scottish close
what are you irish i don't know i wasn't
doing a good job okay i wasn't doing it
it takes me a little sheep stealing
faster just the words i used to try to
get in the flow of things like that you
know it's like off the lilt
but i remember it got cut and so but
anyway you know i would i remember that
moment when i kissed a man i wonder if
it's more memorable for men than it is
for women because women are supple and
beautiful we're just kind of like and
men are hairy and and i think there's
there's like
societal weird i feel like like
straight men will get very uh
uncomfortable or weird and i don't know
i feel like women are more like
i don't get uncomfortable at all i'll
kiss a dude
did you just get uncomfortable well no
i'll kiss you
okay that's fine i mean unless you
wanted me to or or no if i had to if we
were acting in a scene together if the
situation called for it of course
situation called for it yeah i'm not
scared like that i'm a thespian for
god's sakes yeah i don't i don't i don't
know what that says about me but yeah no
i don't i i don't remember i i think i
like block out chunks of my life
honestly but but those kissing scenes so
you you they don't even affect you at
all if i have to make out with kyler
great great i like kyler i love working
with her yeah it's going to be fun and
comfortable and a great atmosphere and
do you enjoy it yeah they i mean her and
i it's crazy
you know these shows are like chaos and
there's
there's three units going at the same
time you're doing three you're being
shuttled between multiple episodes so
her and i had a really fantastic work
relationship and we're like work wives
so
like we would order each other lunch
every day we would you know she did the
morning coffee when i would do the
afternoon we had our same drinks that we
like we really were like work wives in
that way and and um
and when things were bad we would kind
of cocoon and so we had intimacy in our
in our real relationship and so the more
that grew it just felt more and more
comfortable it got tricky with kovid too
because we weren't really supposed to as
much um which was unfortunate do you
work out a kissing scene like i i
remember having to like like oh if i do
this and i do this and you choreograph
things is that how you do it like what
if i kissed you on the neck and then i
kissed your lips only if camera is like
that doesn't work for us but we we were
so comfortable with each other after a
while that we didn't even which again
coveted officers were like you have to
tell us we would just kind of feel out
scenes and and do it
wow we were lucky you're a pro i i think
if i didn't like who i was working
opposite of it would be tough it would
be hard i'm sure there's been guys
you've had you've had to kiss and you're
like i didn't like that i don't want to
have to kiss this guy
you know what's weird what
and i and i and i just did not happen
with kyle and i've talked to her about
it because i remember our kissing scenes
very clearly but with men
um like when i was on jane the virgin
like i would black out kind of
the male kissing scenes like i would
like remember starting it and then just
kind of like not remember were you just
method acting or you just weren't like i
don't know maybe a coping mechanism
getting paid to do this and it's weird
right but i wouldn't i wouldn't remember
and and poor brett dyer who i was
opposite was always like i don't know
whether to be offended by that i'm like
oh it's not personal i do this all the
time but but not not with women you just
kind of zone out but with women you feel
more comfortable yeah maybe yeah that's
actually i haven't unpacked that yet
i'll tackle that in therapy tomorrow
yeah well maybe tackle that in therapy
and then we could talk about that yeah
yeah yeah we'll do that because that's
interesting yeah huh yeah i want to talk
about that more but we won't
um this is [ __ ] talking with ozzy
tespai yeah i said it right yeah uh
these aren't my patrons my lovable
patrons go to patreon.com inside of you
and you could ask questions to the
guests and uh help the podcast but so
these are some questions you could go
rapid fire and great were you going to
say something i just these are questions
from you or from these are questions
from uh from fans from patrons
i'd never heard patrons use this yeah a
patron patreon is a is a place where
people can go online and they support
the podcast so they support the podcast
in many different ways and so these are
patrons that had questions great let's
do it little lisa who is the prankster
on the set of supergirl
uh
i don't
i don't there was you kind of
pranked don't you
no i don't feel like anyone really
not david david seems like he'd prank
no definitely not she's like nope david
does not no
uh maybe maybe nicole i don't know
everyone's an adult and just kind of to
get their job done so i don't know about
pranks
yeah i didn't say they didn't get their
job done i mean you could still go and
sit and get your job done
maybe like one of our one of our camera
operators rosie likes to do like during
soccer term he'll do fun teasing things
so maybe more crew than cast all right
yeah michelle k what's one thing people
would be surprised to learn about you
um
can you sing
no can you dance no i mean i did not
what not like professionally
i'm pretty untalented
i don't i don't believe that for a
second uh
i don't know i'm an overthinker
i'm a major overthinker which i've
shared now it's like in my head you
think about things too much things that
haven't happened yeah but that's what i
do and they always say if you're
thinking about the future you're you're
having it's anxiety and you're thinking
about the past it's depression right
you're focusing on that i live in those
spaces i kind of do too yeah yeah we got
to be able to be more present don't we
yeah i feel like i'm the duck with the
feet but like maybe looks a lot calmer
but i'm overthinking everything you know
what
i think
the therapist once told me this if you
can't control it
and you can't change it
shelve it
so this is the situation i can't change
this right now i can't control this
let it go let's shelve it to when i can
deal with it and that does help me
that's really great also get out of my
mind
i scream at myself
in the middle of the street yeah yeah uh
leanne who has been a positive influence
in your life and helped shape the person
that you are today whoa these are these
are men they're these are not rapid fire
they're going for they could be rapid
fire or they could be thoughtful you
know you kind of
i'm my mom you know i my my mom i grew
up with a single mom and and she told me
i could do anything and when i went to
quit she's like you just keep pushing so
my mom
but not dad
not so much dad my dad and i have a
better adult relationship does dad say i
love you
not a lot i'm proud of you not a lot
now
but not not as much growing up as
definitely my mom yeah yeah we need that
as kids yeah and i think there's
something cultural with that with being
east african or you know area trips
between saudi arabia and yemen and like
east african middle eastern culture
where uh kids are kind of like seen and
uh not heard and there's not as much
like words of affirmation it's like i
love you because you have a home and i
feed you and i pay for your schooling
you know and um my dad used to say that
who puts a roof over your head i'm not a
good father yeah i don't have a meal on
the table yeah i go oh so parenting's
just about it putting a roof over my
head is that what you're saying it's not
i i think the most important thing is
emotional connection i think it's mostly
about i'm proud of you son i love you
son
things like that connecting but i think
that's a
it's just it's a different time period
where they grew up in it's how
how they were loved and raised you know
what they were shown yeah what they
define as as
being the head of a household or taking
care of their family is is different
than what we think now so yeah yeah dev
nixon death do you
[Laughter]
damn
do you personally think it's essential
or at least helpful to know a bit about
comics for playing such a character or
not
i i did also they they let me i had a
say in my designing my super suit which
was great i think they people just lost
their mind the last year and we're like
yeah it's fine she'll fig you figure it
out so i i
do love the comics i i'm a big um
um bumblebee fan and mal duncan who's a
version of the guardian and um i just we
co-designed the suit with a lot of that
intentions what didn't you do
i did a lot this last year it was great
for my that's gonna be great because i
could see you now i could see you as a
director i don't want to direct i have
zero desire i bet you turn i bet you
eventually you will
the thought of being in pressure and
having to manage a lot of people sounds
like my version of health we'll create
them just create and write i just if i
can do it in my bed
that's like the sweet spot getting to if
you could do it in your bed yeah right
oh yeah i was like
you can't do you can't direct in your
bed right you can't direct yeah so
there's a that's a no-go for me this is
now how i look at my green implants of
deciding what i want to do
i can i can write in my bed zone dana s
i loved your episode with uh black lives
matter made me cry and feel included in
the discussion gave all the correct
things to say to our allies such a
heartfelt episode thank you
i was hoping i was hoping that it would
help with conversation wow are you
getting offered to write things more
things now yeah you are yeah so you got
some things in the works yeah
can't talk about it no but i'm excited
and and uh
it's very it's exciting i i like
i don't know it's hard going back to not
to just acting for me
um well we need more female voices yeah
we need you to
do it
keep doing it you're good at it i love
it and it makes me really happy and and
and there's there's a lot of stories
that haven't been told and so i'm like
okay let's let's do it and again i just
collected kind of great people from
different shows and writers and
partnering with them on different ideas
and
trying to get that stuff made but
but supergirl is special because it was
um
when do you get to write your superhero
coming out story like never
you're the
first arrowverse actor to have a writing
credit in arrowverse series yeah i think
i think that's first for berlanti ever
and then
second uh for the the network are you
glad the season the after justin oh yeah
yeah are you going i ran into recently
and told him i was coming on your
podcast because i know his wife was just
jane the virgin
uh he was like he's the best he was like
come over and have some tequila with me
and his wife after we talk about it nice
um this has been a real treat by the way
is is the
did you cry at the you know that it's
the last seat you're done right yeah
yeah yeah did you cry in the final
episode
like this is it so the fight the finale
this the series finale is is kyle and
his wedding so um
and they built out a full wedding i mean
it was
this gorgeous estate that they took over
i mean you walked in and you're like oh
this is somebody that has a lot of money
is getting married it was beautiful and
so
uh and every cast member
from the beginning pretty much was there
and uh
and mccod walked me down the aisle and
so there was a lot of it was very it was
an emotional experience to have a
wedding scene and then i think
that environment created a lot of um
extra emotion but
not not until i was pretty solid and um
katie mcgrath said that when when they
did like my final goodbye was smiling
she was like you didn't look very upset
i was like was i smiling she was like it
was disturbing it was like a plastered
smile on your face but i was like ready
i was ready to move on and then i said
bye to a couple of crew members i'm
really close with like our first id bob
and i was giving them very personal
gifts and notes and i burst into tears
uh really yeah isn't it always the crew
guys that you're just like you feel so
boys at home with yeah they're
protectors too we have like did you have
any of those guys like jd
the jd phil supergirl or did you work
with glenn winter at all yeah glenn is
the best sounds great
yeah
yeah and then we we had
and you know
rosie was from the flash and paul our b
cam operator and our ads like those guys
were very they're protectors in the best
way and so
uh this show is it's a lot and when
you're on location it's a lot and they
just were
for me personally i i you know had
different experiences on the show some
were good some were bad and but they
were always like a solid um stable kind
like place to land and so saying bye to
them was was the hardest yeah will you
miss it
do you miss it
i'm gonna miss being a superhero
um i miss our i miss the crew
i think it felt right to be done right
um
the fear and you always want to do like
one more season
but it was done and and you could feel
it and and
a lot of people were already mentally
done like they i kind of came on later i
wasn't on since the beginning i can't
imagine doing 100 something episodes of
television
but
it felt right
yeah
well i loved having you on did you enjoy
it today i did this was like really easy
i could do this all day yeah i really
had fun yeah i don't like to talk too
much but like you know an hour to me is
like it's it's did we do an hour
probably did we do an hour ryan
yeah wow look at that doesn't that just
fly
you're so good at this oh thanks uh you
know i was a little nervous because i we
don't know each other no and we don't
you know it's just like i i it's not
like i watch supergirl every day
and so you're like what are you doing
like what would you do every episode you
just talk to a human being so hopefully
you know and we're both big on therapy i
feel like that's like then you you know
it's important it's important and you
opened up and you opened up and you
shared with the audience and they're
gonna they'll gravitate towards you
because they like that they like when
people open up and they just if they
learn something from you which i learned
something from you
and um so thank you thank you thank you
for having me and blanche wait i had you
and blanche and ryan and ryan sorry that
i said blanche first but that's that
happens yeah pretty fantastic
she's pretty cute yeah she is a cute dog
all right thanks again for being here
thanks for having me
thank you ozzy tesfai um great interview
just really humble and sweet and easy to
talk to
and uh i didn't know her i didn't know
her at all and uh you know a lot of
times when you don't know someone i get
a little nervous i get a little you know
oh my god i want them to like me i want
them to enjoy themselves i want them to
maybe come back and
you know you can only control what you
can control ryan can i see those those
have been the best ones recently the
ones where you're like i don't know this
person i don't know what we're going to
talk about you guys talk and it's fine
and it's easy they turn out great i
think you're right because you'll learn
about somebody and that's kind of what
this is about you want to learn i want
to learn yeah yeah
i mean i learn about somebody
either way but when i don't know them at
all i learn a ton yeah and so do you
so thank you ozzytus5 for coming on the
podcast you're welcome back whenever you
want uh remember to follow us on the
handles uh at inside of you podcast on
um
instagram and facebook at insideepod on
the twitter
and uh what else um make sure you uh
listen watch uh tell your friends to do
the same
and if you want to join patreon the
lovable loving patrons that i have
patreon.com inside of you is that what
it is and they're fantastic they've
become so such great friends such a
great community they give back to the
podcast they help to keep the cut
podcast afloat and i'm going to read
those names off now and be sure to if
you're in the giving spirit
echoesofhope.org for foster youth
foodonfoot.org for the homeless
situation here in los angeles um tell
them i sent you and also the ronald
mcdonald house you can't uh do wrong by
donating to those guys
um yeah and uh food on foot if you give
25 they'll receive fifty dollars they
get fifty so go food on foot.org
for more information right now we're
gonna read off uh our lovely
patrons uh these are the top tier
patrons they get boxes from me every
couple of months
because they give the most
that you can give
on the podcast on the on the patreon
thing
are you still doing your uh
your better help still you're still
working with better help i am uh yeah
and i have a therapist right now who's
really stuck and she's uh really uh
hands-on really yeah so you're digging
it i am yeah that's good man i just got
a new therapist too and uh it's helping
me yeah
in fact i told her she goes what are you
thinking i go well i thought that i just
didn't want to be on this conversation
and i'm having anxiety talking to you
and then all of a sudden 20 minutes in i
feel really comfortable so know that
even you know even myself i when i'm
talking to a therapist i get nervous i'm
anxious and then all of a sudden it
starts to dissipate and i start to feel
comfortable and let go and that's when
the real work
comes in you know comes through yeah uh
here are the top tier patrons here we go
nancy d leah asks
what yes yes sarah v little lisa kiko
jill e brian h mama lauren g nico p
jerry w robert uh b jason
w kristen okay emilia oh alison l raj c
josh d it's joshua emily
uh f
s yes s c j p samantha
m jennifer and stacy l gin
uh z
i forget take a guess on gen
c s s you got through quite a few of
them without messing up
jamal
uh
f yes janelle b kimberly
e mike d
e eldon supremo 99 more ra mira santiago
m chad
w leanne p janine r maya
p
maddie
i s belinda l n chris
r h dave jesus
j h i'm out spider-man chase sheila
g brad
d ray h tabitha t mr
uh ed mr m
liliana a michelle k michael s talia m
betsy d l'oreal chad l rochelle nathan e
marion megkay janelle p
dan and big stevie w angel m rhiannon c
cory k super
sam coleman
uh coolers coleman coolers coleman g
coleman ghoulers
dev nixon michelle a liz i jeremy c andy
t cody r sebastian k gavinator david c
john b brandy d javore camille s the c
getting down to the nitty-gritty here
joey m willie f christina e adelaide and
jeffrey m omar i lena n eugene and lee
hello guys chris p nikki g corey ktb
patricia heather l jake b thank you
patrons top patrons thank you all
patrons for sticking with inside of your
podcast and with me
it means a [ __ ] ton that you guys
uh give so much to the podcast and you
support me so much and i will never
forget it and i'm gonna keep doing this
podcast until you um stop supporting me
i guess right
yeah sure what else can i do
uh happy holidays we got a couple of
great episodes coming up so do not miss
them put them in your calendar every
tuesday i'll be here with you or
whenever you decide to listen to the
show from the hollywood hills in
hollywood california i am michael
rosenbaum i'm ryan taylor that's ryan
taylor's right over there a little wave
to the camera and thanks for allowing me
to be inside of each and every one of
you today and i hope you have a glorious
freaking week be good to yourselves guys
[Music]